oh what's the main trap in the stafford
the main trap in the stafford there's so
many traps
so starting from this position which is
like the the main starting point
and most e4 players will get to this
because it's just so natural
um it's also objectively the best
approach for white
um i mean where to start
so the the fun so the fun trap is d3
bishop c5 bishop g5
and then you can take on e4 say oh no my
queen
and then deliver mate
so this has occurred did i just do
close to 700 times on the chest
yeah 94 is just yeah it's completely
winning if knight takes e4
bishop e3 you can take and still keep
throwing punches
here you take and then you you're
winning material
in every line
i had a game at a game where my opponent
play queen e2
yeah this one i took
takes and then very nice move king d8
reminiscent of that king d7 idea we saw
earlier
just to free open the the file for the
rook
so white played bishop e2 breaking the
pin
but then queen c1 and
opponent resigns given that after this
white loses a queen
so that's one trap um
there's another nice trap if white plays
e5
knight e4 d3 bishop c5 is winning
using some similar theme against f2
if white takes then you can take here
and you're winning the queen
takes takes uh if king e2 bishop g4
so every line you're just like throwing
punch after punch
uh if white plays d4 here which is like
the best move
there's still traps with queen h4
hitting f2
and most natural move is g3
uh oh maybe queen f3 yeah queen f3 is a
better move
but g3 is also natural but it's a
mistake because knight takes g3
hitting the rook after f takes there's
queen e4 winning the row
how many traps was that that was three
oh the most common trap is knight c3
bishop c5 d3 you can also get this from
d3 bishop c5 knight c3 so many like
amateurs will just play this
instinctively
and then knight g4 and
you're winning back material really the
only move for white to defend f2 is
bishop e3
you win back upon it's best to take with
knight and then
your bishop dominates
oh another so another trap that a lot of
people fall into
is bishop c4 here like very natural
developing move
and that's the great thing about
stafford gambit so only natural
moves are just splunders in this case
after bishop c4 there's knight g4
uh hitting f2 in this case there's no
bishop e3
most players i've encountered castle and
then queen h4 is just crushing
had a few games where white will play h3
knight f2 queen f3 and then double check
wherever the king moves you play knight
f2 and then you mate
on each one so
and you can see like based on the the
chess stats
like how how many games opponents will
fall into this
and especially the the win percentage
for black
uh now just to show if white plays queen
f3 here
which is a tricky move oh two people
have sadly taken on f2 and gotten mated
i assume yeah so don't take on f2 but
play knight e5
best move forking the queen and bishop
if queen e2 then queen h4 is very strong
and the threat is to take because the
queen's overworked queen's defending
this and this
so you just want to take twice and then
win c4
um i think g3 if g3 then queen h3 and
bishop g4 is coming
so it's just really really difficult
also bishop g4 is a threat
because the f1 can't move whoa it's gm
rains
gifting subs thanks gm marines
i'll read off the sub names in just a
moment i want to share one more
like really favorite trap because we've
only scratched the surface
um favorite trap time i know i've shown
this before
but it doesn't get old so i'm showing it
again
uh knight c3 bishop c5 let's say white
plays bishop e2
and what i'm about to show i've had
most often against like strong players i
thought once against kustiniok
who's like a former world women's
champion
i had it against tatev abrahamian and
like a casual blitz game
um probably like a few other gm's as
well
so this is a safe move
uh trying just trying to prevent
knight g4 here i like to play h5
let's say y plays another safe move h3
this is already
like close to winning for for black
um and it's incredible variation
[Music]
sometimes i'll show this to like strong
players and have them calculate until
black's winning
but for this case i'll just show after
queen d4
castling there's knight g4
and part of this line is based on
computer preparation
but the idea so the idea of course is
we're just
attacking f2 if white takes takes
and then let's say y plays an innocent
move d3
this is already force mate because
how to stop it if g3 this pawn is pinned
this is just mate and then
so already here white's in big trouble
uh because queen e5 is just a deadly
threat
yeah this is very fishing pole like so i
think the only way to really keep the
game
going is if bishop takes g4 we still
have queen e5 there's no f4
uh because the pawns pinned if this we
we just take
and there's always this queen g3 idea
with mating in the end
so the best try for white is to play g3
and then the line is is incredible we
play queen e5
again threatening made in one
also threatening this so d4 doesn't work
because of this
so king g2 and now black to move
play the only winning move see how sharp
chat is
yeah oh i barely know the rules knows
the rules
and even more yeah bishop takes f2
and if rook takes f2
uh what do we do here i'm actually
trying to remember
yeah we have to play queen h5 uh idea
queen h3
and this is really bad for white
because this is what is this this is
just a mate right queen h3 king g1 queen
h1
if a move like rook f4 is played we
check
takes and we're winning everything
oh rook f5 might be the best move but
okay we can see
black is already completely winning here
so there's a funny line king takes f2
after which we check here check here
and then i think the engine will give
bishop e6
and this is also completely winning for
black
some idea of queensland castling with
check
lights king is just in the center so
this is why i play stafford gambit like
there's so many traps like
especially this one it's it's very easy
for strong players to walk into
um now i usually just play it in like
blitz or bullet
because there are
options for white to essentially refute
it or
get get it so black has no compensation
um oh i can show one more
i'm really going in depth i'll show one
more just kind of funny line
if we go back to this position let's say
this
bishop c5 and then h3
then
yeah i've had this position before so
black can take here and after it takes
knight takes e4
it's a crazy line i think objectively
it's equal
if white plays king g1 you can force a
draw so if you're playing like a strong
player you can
you can get away with just a quick draw
um
there's a funny line i think king is the
king f3
yeah king f3 and then castling
the engine will give a plus for white
but this is not so clear
especially like king jake's e4 people
can have fun analyzing
on their own
um so anyway i've i lost count how many
traps there were
but i i hope people are inspired
i'll probably put this whole thing on
youtube um
i've been meaning to do a stafford
gambit video for a while
so i i think i shared most of my
my main prep so anything else i left out
i guess if i put this on youtube and
people have questions
about specific variations feel free to
comment
um there are like engine refutations
but i think the the risk versus reward
there's so much potential for reward in
this line
so anyway yeah hope you enjoyed that
stay tuned for more content
and subscribe